depuis le mois d'août beanie wells a
investi ce hangar derrière le marché aux
poissons
une toute nouvelle gueule il voit le
jour dessiné par laurent mas son futur
patron lui-même charpentier de métier
à ses côtés ce soir joris et wils
s'affairent autour des bois dressés des
poteaux bien carré en cèdre qu'il a
fallu soigneusement arrondir et
emmailloté de bandes de protection
il y avait un temps de cela les trois
garçons avaient déjà ce rêve dans la
cour de l'école la scolarisation donc à
la création on se revoyait parce qu'elle
n'est pas dans la même classe et on vend
pas en l'air enfin des jumeaux disait
que un jour on aura un équipage si aux
yeux
en fait il vous a fait quelque chose de
bon et c'était avec des gars si aux yeux
pour les gagner c'est comme si c'est un
rêve qui devient réalité en fait qui
serait en réalité
après on verra par la suite si ça
pouvait mois se concrétiser puisque ses
parents se lance laguiole prendra la mer
pour la première fois d'ici fin octobre
elle sera baptisée lent mais des beautés
et son profil top secret se veut à la
fois plus stable et plus rapide que les
autres champions de bébés yole beanie
wells a réussi les tests de la
fédération ce week-end pour accéder aux
championnats de grande gueule la saison
qui s'annonce verra beaucoup
d'ajustements sur l'embarcation avant de
prétendre chatouiller les mapipi le
nouveau projet c'est une nouvelle équipe
et c'est voilà ils connaissent pas les
formes que à part quelques-uns
donc ils vont être du matin peut pas
bluffer meys review c'est sous ces
nouveaux sénat ne paie à petit détail
donc voilà c'est ça le charme de ce
projet en fait je pense à près de deux
ans enfin des victoires
donc il faut faut pas être trop trop
pressé ça passe quand une nouvelle
embarcation et les sponsors on a tous
qu'on va aller pour va gagner ça serait
marrant ça l'esprit l'équipage en effet
séduit les sponsors les entreprises qui
reviennent sur le tour après des années
d'absence l'appaloosa total caraïbes et
oyo l automobile et ce n'est pas un
détail car 35000 euros sont nécessaires
pour réaliser ce rêve
ce conte même qu'au village de
participer à une fabrication telle que
celle ci est
bon avec le bâton donc l'eau en masse
une aiguille de a à z et puis sinon une
chasse quoi bon malchance cette saison
une quinzième viol vient donc renforcer
la flottille l'équipage de laurent mas
ne portera pas l'étendard d'une commune
et comprendra même des coursiers
guadeloupéens